foreign
.com look Adam and Eve is still offering
amazing prices can you believe it
they've been offering amazing prices
Sid's jump and now they're still doing
it wild it's wild at adamandeve.com get
you're probably like what do I get five
ten percent fifty percent off you get 50
off plus free shipping that's 50 off an
adventurous new toy slippery Lube or
almost anything else you desire our
podcast listeners will get 50 off almost
every item and
free shipping just use code Lifeline at
checkout and you'll get 50 off doesn't
matter what you choose you've been
packaged discreetly nobody will know
what it is and it'll be sent to you for
free so not only will you save money on
gas movies and date night dinners out uh
but this is the item that will can you
continue to save your money uh and
deliver tons and of fun and satisfaction
go to adamandeve.com select any one item
use code Lifeline
l-i-f-e-l-i-n-e this is an exclusive
offer specific to this podcast so be
sure to support our show and use this
code Lifeline ticket not just the 50 off
but also the 100
free shipping code Lifeline go to
adamandeve.com right now if you're a fan
of ours and your sex positive let's do
this Lifeline is an advice show for
entertainment purposes only if you need
real help or advice please please seek a
therapist or licensed professional
[Music]
yeah dude it's Lifeline episode whatever
it is 20 [__] we don't know dude we
just keep going see we're not in it for
the numbers right we're in it for what
we're waiting for the art you know the
art of the podcast we're basically
Guggenheim yeah we're the Guggenheim
episode everybody just this episode or
what no we're all we're always
Guggenheim episodes but I'll tell you
this you know it's going to be the crazy
guggenheimer episode October 19th your
birthday we're doing Lifeline live and
it's October 19th Matt's birthday show
and you can get tickets Below in the
link in the comments and uh you called
in and we talked to you directly uh and
we can um you know get more information
about you and talk to you and [__]
you and [__] with you and uh it's
gonna be a lot of fun so do that and
we're gonna have some sick ass sweet ass
[__] pimping ass surprises too yeah
we will have surprises uh and um we are
also going to uh what was it that we
decided signed a merch for everybody
that makes it actually on the show
yes that's what we're doing we're doing
signed merch for everybody that makes it
on the show of lifeline and that's
what's up October 19th 6 p.m specific
specific
um and uh watch lifeline.com is where
you get tickets that's watch
lifeline.com you can get it down there
in the uh in the link there I am touring
[Applause]
yeah I will be in Raleigh North Carolina
Savannah and uh Georgia and Tempe
Arizona Denver Albany Cheyenne Wyoming
uh go get those tickets at
crystallia.com
and uh that you want to do your thing uh
mattelia.com it's about a promo what you
do is you go to matalia.com
you sign up you sign in you get you get
a [__] 20 or 40 minute advice session
with yours truly Mr [__]
Pimpin Pippin M diesel mattelia himself
worst name uh and you come to me with
your problems and I help you [__]
solve them everybody thinks I'm a liar
or no I don't think you're a liar
everyone thinks I'm a liar I said I was
gonna only wear purple from now on and
look what I'm wearing dude I'm doing my
uh pure Spectrum should be Duke uh oil
here you get 10 off I swallow it first
before you do I gotta let it you gotta
let it
Let It Go on your tongue for 20 seconds
but then wait just wait while we're live
let me do my liar thing everybody
thought it was a [__] liar okay
because I was talking about how I'm only
wearing purple now until at least the
end of the year and look at me that's
gonna be too much purple you started it
way too early look at your boy look at
your kid
[Music]
go check it out check it out so I let it
ruminate I'll let it ruminate right
there that okay I know
okay so wow so we're all good yeah
that's cool I let it ruminate and then
[__] I'm chillaxing now you know
that's what CBD does helps you chillax
so uh yeah and go you can do this in the
notes description you can get 10 off all
your CBD needs uh and type in code
Lifeline anyway dude what's been
cracking
uh
uh same old [__] man you know what I
mean yep same stuff dude what's uh
what's cracking I brought Calvin to the
um to the playground earlier today and
uh you know he's real good with all the
[__] and then and then he's in the
jungle gym doing it and then another kid
shows up and he goes and I'm like no
just play with the [__] kid oh okay
and I say ask him and then I say and
then I say hey Calvin say hi say hi and
he goes hi to the kid and then I say say
What's your name and he says I'm Cal
what's your name and then the kid
doesn't do it back and then I'm like
well the [__] you know at least like
[__] can you work with me and then the
dad's like Mateo tell him you're Mateo
and then and then the kids just [__]
doing other [__] and I'm like have him
ask him again he's like what's your name
I'm Calvin and then the kid's just doing
literally he he just goes and starts
grabbing his inner thighs to my son what
kind of [__] loser is that I don't
know but Mateo that was Mateo yeah and
so well you know isn't the dad that'd be
hilarious and so so
[__] I got it Calvin so
um
so anyway so then uh so now now I'm
trying to get my my you know my kid
assimilated with other other people yeah
yeah but he's still still early I know I
know he's two he's two he's two and a
half so three is when they really start
like hopefully like making friends and
sharing stuff and they sprout when
they're three they fully Bloom and
Sprout because right now like here uh
here hold this Perrier like right now
this is what a two-year-old would do
okay
that's mine show them what a
three-year-old does go like this kind of
have that
am I three two or how old am I you
didn't give me directions yeah you could
be three okay so I'm three can I have
that
can I have that
no I want both I want mine can I have
that can I have yours yeah they do like
this
I want that back that's what they do
that is what they would do yeah so um
yeah so which is a little bit you know
more advanced so for sure I guess two to
five is when the [__] crazy [__]
happens two to five is the most
important Zone if two to five is [__]
then you are [__] yeah also the rest
of your life yeah true but also you got
to do skin to skin right when the baby
comes out otherwise you're pretty [__]
too what's that about though like I've
heard that and I believe it I don't know
what is it about you know what it sounds
like some [__] [__] that like they do
that they definitely do so much in
Hawaii you know well yeah you're saying
because they don't usually always wear
shirts down there okay yeah and they're
like you have to you know oh that's the
spirit yeah yeah yeah the spirit of the
baby and the mother and the and this you
have to get the baby and the spirit and
the mother and the father and everyone
that is has ever talked to the father
needs to touch without shirts and you're
just like 350 people in a room and then
you're just like oh okay 450 people in
the room what is it a [__] Stadium
yeah for every birth you know what I
heard about [__] birth too though
like when they put the baby on the
mother's chest the first time they they
don't [__] cut the cord right away oh
really in Hawaii no man everywhere oh oh
no no no this is not specific to Hawaii
not for us what did they do with cow I
think we I cut the cord when
um like three weeks ago
I cut the cord as soon as he was born
cut the cord and then they put it on
okay on Mommy okay and then I I was
jealous so I went I go like this too
well I after she had some time I took
him oh okay yeah yeah how long was it on
her chest before you took it on your
chest
[Music]
you know
I don't know 20 minutes was it weird
just like stripping and taking off your
shirts
well they're just like okay take off
your shirt now dad is that what it was
like uh uh yeah shoot no Crystal was
like take your shirt off and like do the
skin the skin I was like [__] yeah okay
I'm not with the nurse I was like oh
shut up so the so the uh socal's well
adjusted now then yeah I mean he's great
yeah what would if you didn't do that
yeah would he be like rampaging right
now yeah it's like burning houses down
and [__] I'd be like yeah we'd be
like what the [__] is going on we'd be
like what's that noise is he what is he
playing [__] Nine Inch Nails
[__] you lacking animals looking at the
ornaments in the crib just like put the
thumb tank there's a star tank I wanna
feel you from the insane oh [__]
wow
oh bad acting I'm good okay bad acting
as a drug as a druggie uh all right cool
so let's do let's do Lifeline in the
news all right now that we're all caught
up so somber how you did it talk like
this not because I [__] my throat okay
cool uh Lifeline in the news here we go
you go okay the Library of Congress sent
lizzo those are the some those are words
already that I just can't stand Lent
lizzo scent okay well I uh yeah okay
send it to her they lent it to it well
the library of contests contest the
Library of Congress
lent lizzo a crystal flute which
belonged to James Madison the fourth U.S
president she was apparently the first
person to play this flute saying this is
from the early 1800s this was a gifted
James Madison almost rub from a French
Crystal flute designer to celebrate his
second term there was a fire and the
only two things that were saved were a
portrait of George Washington and this
Crystal flute right here
weird priorities uh not nine people
burned alive we didn't grab them uh I am
get the flute get the painting leave
Jeff
um I am the first person to ever play it
so you're about to hear what it sounds
like for the first time thank you to the
Library of Congress
uh history is freaking cool you guys
well you know what oh that's the quote
from lizzo yeah lizzo said all that yeah
oh you didn't you didn't do uh so she
quoted it so that's a quote from this is
from the early 1800s this was a gift
with the whole story okay here's the
thing that that might take on all this
uh first and foremost the reaction I saw
from people on like the right like
conservative oh yeah was so [__]
stupid it was overboard yeah they got so
mad why do you what yeah what thank you
what it's a flute this is something you
go like this to us [__] stupid or
just like Alexa yeah well at most you go
I'm not stupid
yeah at least you go ah yeah you know
right so it's like that's the only good
reaction from well at least you go wow
that's great yeah at the least in the
least you like the that on the other end
of the spectrum you go you go wow that's
that's really great that America has
come so far right that you know we went
to they you know they saved this Crystal
flu because it was so important in White
America and now right you have you know
an overweight minority uh woman of my of
of of color playing this flute in front
of thousands of people how much America
has changed my my right but you don't
say overweight anymore you say fat
because overweight presumes that there
is a proper weight and she's over you
say fat now she's over the weight that
she should know but but but preferred
it's preferred you call you say fat it's
a it's over the weight that she should
be okay but I'm just telling you call it
say Lord a person that's like oh it's so
great for society what they would say
about her is that she's fat so you did
about it that sounds worse you did a bad
acting I know but that's what you do you
did a bad acting it's like how the the
small person they want us it's like that
that doesn't sound right to me a lot of
it doesn't sound right like I remember
when it was made at least it has its own
thing and now it's small person it's
like oh okay
uh also uh yeah yeah they got terms for
everything that's bad whatever so pretty
soon you're gonna have to be like
calling murderers like premature life
takers yeah yeah yeah yeah you can't
[__] you can't call murderers
murderers wow that sounds like a [__]
here at premature life takers um so uh
we believe euthanasia so the advice here
is just chill the [__] out yeah the
advice is chill but also the advice here
is if you're going to save things from a
burning building uh uh you know grabbing
the crystal flute is maybe uh should be
less on your priority this would all be
[__] bypassed if you didn't save the
[__] Crystal flute I have a question
though now who's the person that signs
off on lizzo getting to do it and why
has it never been played until now that
is very weird who what is this yeah like
there were people like could I play that
and they're like oh no and then and now
they're watching Liz on they go
yeah I asked for you got you know you
know what I mean like you got like
[__] Sam Rockwell at home like I
wanted to [__] when I did Green Mile
they were gonna do that on the bread
carpet and now Liza Billy Joel you know
yeah I just don't get how you could care
in any way it's not like some famous
American artifact nobody even [__]
knew about no I know until lizzo played
it I know people are mad about other
it's not like [__] Harriet Tubman's
[__] wardrobe she came out [__] which
by the way I think that's more power to
her but uh all right cool well let's do
the next one
people are going nuts after making these
butterboards uh
uh is is that is that really what they
said people are going nuts making these
butterboards virals social media food
trend
of spreading butter or cream cheese on a
cutting board adding some topics and
scraping it up with bread or crackers so
you're [__] disgusting oh dude you do
this if you're overweight and I said
overweight it's not fat no both you're
fat if you do that it's technically even
if you're thinning you do that you
become a fatty third way to say it is
fast dude even obese is wrong I think
it's fat
I don't know man that's the preferred
it's disgusting if you're gonna do that
you have to eat the whole board
that's that's not and everything and
[__] out splinters it's weird because
people are so obsessed with health on
social media and yet [__]
[__] doing this [__] yep stop
don't do the board with the thing it's
so lazy dude like they're like I don't
want to butter it one by one I just want
a [__] butter a big thing and then
scoop and scoop and scoop and scoop
until I'm [__] fat the the thing
about this is people will work so hard
to be lazy it's like you're doing all
this work up front though yeah
this is busy work you don't need to do
it don't do it don't do busy work get
the butter put it on the [__] thing
and sprinkle some [__] on it if you want
any bite and then you'll probably eat
less of it if you do it one by one you
get halfway through with the board and
you're like what would I do with it now
I gotta eat it and then you won't be a
Lardo and you'll be [__] fat as hell
all right next one
um Tom Brady and Giselle what's your
advice for Super Rich famous hot people
going through divorce wow okay so
um are they actually going through a
divorce or what I know that she left him
a little bit because he wanted to play
another game again another game you know
hired divorce lawyer they did they hired
divorce lawyers he unretired yeah I know
that at 45 right uh hey man just retire
I agree you're old dude I agree you have
to retire at some point because it's
football you know what I mean it's not
like you're a stand-up comedian or a
[__] go out politician and just be a
young man now with a very beautiful wife
and three great children go be a really
rich businessman or something like you
have so many [__] Rings everybody
knows you're like the greatest [__]
quarterback who ever lived the
winningest at least like hang them up
dude also I don't like the hanging them
up and then being like Oh wait wait wait
announcing the retirement time Jay-Z
retired at [__] 33 and now he's
[__] and then he got then he got big
dude [__] Steven Soderbergh retired
from filmmaking and then he made a movie
like later that year oh really it's so
annoying yeah that is annoying I don't
know it's like make up your [__] mind
and then also just be a dad but we don't
know what's going on man maybe they
honestly don't really love each other
anymore we have no [__] idea in which
that's the case then they should get
divorced they [__] but they have kids
he kind of [__] elbowed his previous
girl out the way too when he met Giselle
you know about that right he doesn't he
have kids with another Bridget Moynihan
yeah he's got an older kid
Bridget Moynihan and he and he elbowed
Bridget out of the way and said I found
him more pimp and Pimpin bride yeah he's
going to start dating lizzo no doubt so
he's gonna I mean and she's gonna play
his Crystal flute okay well
anyway the advice is I think we don't
drive it dude like I why is it always
spilling out so much in the public yeah
I know that's annoying yeah let them
[__] be how about this is the device
for everybody else let him [__] yeah he
wants to throw a ball let him throw a
ball if she wants to [__] throw the
marriage away at the marriage away yeah
you know all right well that's nice
there you go for Lifeline in the news I
could see him being a total [__]
though you know because anyone that's
successful is a [__] right has a high
percentage
yeah all right let's go you know let's
go to the next one
Elon is going to buy Twitter after all
he is oh I didn't know this all right
thoughts should he let Trump back on
does it matter does anything matter
here's what I think about Elon Musk
buying Twitter
okay that's what that's my take on okay
why though because I do who the [__]
[__] cares who owns Twitter right right
Elon Musk just happens to be able to
make a story or [__] get all of a ton
of attention about whatever dude you
gotta let if Twitter already is a
[__] Cesspool you gotta let everybody
on it if you're gonna let anybody on it
or make actual strict rules where people
like if Trump can't be on Twitter then
other there's so many other people that
shouldn't be on Twitter that's the thing
it's like if there's going to be a rule
make it for [__] everybody even the
[__] even people who aren't Donald
Trump like that's the thing the
hippocrite the hypocrisy the hypocrisy
about Twitter is that it definitely
leans left than it does extremely
um but it is a private company that's
just not no no I know that I know that
but so if there's some liberals own it
and they're like we don't want [__]
right-wing [__] on it then that's
their prerogative I know that I know
that I do know that but right now it's
bigger than than just a company it's the
way the world runs so it's changing I
know but you can't just have an
exception for it's like this I know this
I know that you can't have just one
company be like no no you can't do that
but every other company can do whatever
the [__] they want I know that but I
think that this is what you're asking if
if Elon should buy it if he's gonna buy
it what he should do and this is what
you should do if you have a big company
like this I think it's your
responsibility to make rules and make
sure everybody abides by it that's it
because Trump got kicked off for [__]
that people are doing all the time every
day he's already said he's gonna let
Trump back on and right I think about
the whole [__] thing all right cool
so there's the advice my advice for Elon
is just [__] keep everybody uh with
the same rules correct there you go
president or not all right let's get
into some video submissions
hey Matt hey Chris I love you guys and
Chris I cannot wait to see you in
Savannah hence the scad shirt and the
fish is on the wall my question for you
is about dating I hate dating dating
apps are the bane of my existence men do
not know how to approach women anymore
it's really frustrating and I've come to
the conclusion that being a plus-sized
woman who has confidence and has her
life together I think men find me
intimidating like even my friends call
me the mom friend of the friend group
which don't know what that means I'm a
little offended by that and yeah I just
I don't know if it's me or if it's the
men so question number one uh what do
you think of intimidating women and what
is your approach do you shoot your shot
uh and two I'm 25 and I'm fairly
successful in my career so like I
understand that can also be intimidating
should I just shoot my shot and go for
older men that also have their [__]
together
I don't know but can't wait to watch the
podcast and hear from you guys
here's the deal yeah men really are and
I know this just it's anecdotal but a
lot of men that I know single men talk
about how how they are unwilling to
approach women in real life because they
assume that women are only taking like
whatever attention or or
accepting people like possible suitors
on the dating apps oh really first of
all I'm like well if that's [__] true
be the one only guy that does it in real
life and [__] stand out yeah second
second of all moreover the [__] thing
about intimidating women is even more
like these women don't get approached be
the one guy that does dude you [__]
stand out make a [__] difference most
importantly though
if you feel like you can
have like whatever the [__] courage
or the wherewithal uh or the willingness
to approach men that you are attracted
to that [__] absolutely do it don't
go back if that's something you feel
like you might want to do absolutely
it's not like some No-No or something
yeah no it's not a No-No but at least be
like some sort of like
at least you can at least make yourself
seem more available without if you don't
want to go right up to a dude and be
like hey let's hang out sometime that's
the extreme version of that which you
can totally do and that's fine but
there's also the just standing around a
guy thing that you can do because guys
will just if you just look at them for
too long they're like huh maybe we're
supposed to be married right you know
what I mean yeah
um and so you can just do that but I do
I do think for some guys it is
intimidating when a woman has her [__]
together like that like you can just go
right off the bat like she just knows
what she wants she's confident she's if
she's successful that intimidates some
guys you know especially if they're her
age a lot of guys are 25 not they're not
successful you know yeah yeah
um but yeah what's wrong with going for
uh you know successful guys whether
they're older or not nothing wrong with
it if you but I'm saying if you don't
want to do it then don't it's not like
you have to do it because there will be
that confident man or the man who's
willing to at least approach you that
you might like like that man is out
there there's more than one of those men
out there but like if you don't want to
wait and you [__] see a guy that you
do like do it yeah walk up to him and
just be like time to conceive so men are
[__] real afraid right now well yeah
so like yeah to the men out there like
if you're not a [__] piece of [__] if
you're not an [__] you don't have to
be afraid there are women out there like
this very very very [__] attractive
young woman yeah that
are like uh available for you to
approach and if you get rejected who
cares dude well if you get rejected who
cares as the uh you're saying as the
woman no I'm saying for the guys out
there there's beautiful women like this
out there
what the [__] are you all doing dude
if you see him in real life don't be
like well I gotta find him online that's
the opposite of the truth
and you're just telling yourself that so
you don't have to yeah for the guys yeah
that's true but uh I do think it is
weird times and I do think that
sometimes guys are scared to talk to a
woman and I think that rightfully so
even if they aren't a piece of [__] that
they that they should be because like
workplace [__] is just like don't do it
yeah but that's separate I'm saying if
you're at a [__] bar or coffee shop
even just walking on the street
just [__] be the one that stands yo
what's up yeah saying yo what's up be
don't be the one that's a [__] afraid
and thinks it has to be online uh but
for the women out there such as the one
I didn't catch her name but uh
know that it like try to take that into
consideration these men are like afraid
in general so it's not that like you're
not a viable uh person to them you are
they're just like in their own fight I
will say though in Savannah Georgia I'm
sure it's pretty old-fashioned and guys
are just [__] really yeah I mean I'll
be in Savannah soon you can go to
chrisley.com for tickets and I'll see
her I'll plug in them no no but I'm
saying but that's what she said she did
but then she plugged it right so but I
think that um you know so it's probably
very old-fashioned there I don't know
the lack of a better term I believe you
hey darling Oh what's going on is that
what Savannah's like yeah Savannah
Georgia you ever see that movie In the
Garden of Good and Evil the worst
[__] movie oh what is it uh Clint
Eastwood movie based on a book I forget
who wrote it but it's like I mean what's
it like it's like this right it's very
old-timey I'll meet you uh there's no
but kind of weird with like uh okay
unless I'm talk unless I'm okay you just
keep cutting me off with that accent
it's not worth it okay
why what is it done well sorry I'm sorry
I'm done
see and this is what might be it might
be like this if you meet somebody
awkward but darling you know
Hello darling exactly come here I'm
old-fashioned put that phone down let's
talk in real life let's look each other
in the eye and
touch yeah are you ready to splurt Let's
conceive let's touch Uncle if it's okay
got to get your permission yeah yeah
yeah definitely do that okay next
oh this short video probably won't do me
Justice and admitting radio guys I'm the
funniest person in most rooms at a man
which I'm sure you two can relate to all
right that's my question
if you're the funniest person in the
room
and other people in the room catch up on
why you're funny and then they start
picking up your mannerisms or delivery
or pauses to high mean any of that and
then start using back your own yeah
personality on you I mean but shittily
like three levels less funny or
attractive or whatever you're going for
then you then the originator
so that's my question for one do you
notice people do that two does it bother
you because then you almost have to like
reinvent yourself like all right now
that funny [__] that I had going on for
years is no longer funny because of
these [__] there you go you know you
got to keep it moving my language I
think we could swear right yeah
but yeah that's my question people steal
it from you using your own [__] back in
your face shittily to do it what
thanks for the show guys shittily uh uh
yeah I mean that's that that's been
happening since
okay
cool go ahead yeah I just I mean that's
if you're funny that's been happening in
your whole life get [__] used to it
man yeah yeah and it's I think it's good
because it makes you be funnier and
funnier because people will try they'll
like it they'll do it they'll ruin it or
they won't or just you [__] keep
doing it it can be annoying I get it
when I was in high school I would I
would I had like this thing that I was
doing I don't remember what it was at
this point I genuinely don't remember
what it is but Tim Chung would do it and
I would be like oh I remember what it
was
it's a [__] so hard to explain but we
just like remember that whole thing
where we'd be like yeah anyway uh we
would do that yeah yeah so Tim Chung
would do and I'd be like bro you got to
stop doing that man you [__]
confronted him yeah what did he say he
was like why and I was like because it
just it it's what I do and like it
[__] makes me not want to do it whoa
and that's so ridiculous so
confrontational dude I was on the phone
you guys fight no no and he was like so
I can't do it he's like I can't do it I
was like I don't know man it's just like
when I do it I feel like I'm doing it
like you're doing it now and I want to
do it the way I do it I mean so
ridiculous I was [__] 15 yeah anyway
yeah yeah exactly yeah yeah and so wow
so stupid so anyway it was so stupid but
that's what happens you gotta reinvent
yourself but by the way dude what's the
second the second people catch up with
your funny [__] it's old it's old anyway
man but here's the thing if they're
doing it as he says yeah so eloquently
shittily yep then just keep doing it
because you're the only one doing it
well non-shitterly yeah like be the only
one that does it funny yep yeah also you
know it'll be hilarious if you caught if
he'd send his video in and all of his
friends were watching the video and
they're like this guy right he's not
even the funny one right he's the one
that takes from yeah he's a taker dude
um I think that all you got to do is
just keep plowing ahead dude and also
well I make a career of it right like I
you know I I Funny is is like I go on
stage and I'm I I make jokes but like so
I got a whole [__] internet people
are saying like it's a deeper this and
that are like yes you know making sense
to me online I don't like that
everybody's stop but deeper is our thing
but they said it's killing me though oh
but it's your thing too but they don't
do it they don't do it they're saying it
to me and then like not doing it right
oh they don't do it right often but
that's what he's talking about they're
doing it what alas shittily so you'd be
the funny one see now you're this guy in
the video right no I'm not okay but I
think just keep doing it and do it the
right way you know people [__] you
know they want they want to be like
things that they think are funny totally
take it as [__] compliment because it
is taking your [__] because they don't
have their own and that yours is funny
that's why they want to take it
whatever it's not the big good deal it's
not over it dude okay worst therapist
[__] get over it all right cool get
over yourself dude wow where's therapist
all right for this guy in the room get
over it get over yourself okay very mean
next one
Matt my name is Neely I'm from Oklahoma
City um I'm a huge fan of y'all Chris
would love if you did a show in Oklahoma
City sometime
um anyways my question is so my fiance
we actually just got engaged a couple
weeks ago but the other day I noticed
that my toothbrush was wet oh and we've
been together for almost seven years
whoa and I noticed my toothbrush was wet
and I was like I didn't brush my teeth
so I went up to him and I was like did
you use my toothbrush because he didn't
have his and he was like yeah I yeah and
I was like
that's disgusting and he's like no it's
not
so I guess my question is like maybe
Chris would you do that with Kristen or
is that disgusting or is it normal
because we've been together so long
should I not be grossed out by that
I think it's gross but whatever let me
know what y'all think it it's the bane
of my existence right now why because I
and let me tell you why all right I I
like my [__] you know me right okay my
shit's my [__] okay if you want to drink
some of my drink it's yours now okay let
me just chill have my [__] there's very
few things that you get to just kind of
experience in your own body and brushing
your teeth that's one of them okay so
I've noticed the same thing my two parts
wet I walk over I'm like this has been
like two years now I'm like Kristen did
you use my toothbrush and she's like
oh yeah and I'm like oh okay well that's
disgusting so what where's your
toothbrush she's like I couldn't find it
and then I go look for two minutes and I
find it right so look a little bit
harder for your toothbrush also don't
lose a toothbrush also if you lost your
toothbrush walk around with a dirty
mouth that's your Penance here's the
other thing too I bought and I'm not
joking 20 toothbrushes I bought 20
toothbrushes this way oh Kristen these
gold ones are mine I bought them all the
same the gold ones are mine and you have
your blue one okay okay
dude fire a bunch of blue ones or no no
I got her she has a blue one and I got
her she's also there's also like a green
one and a red one and she wants to use
it and like dude she'll just like
willy-nilly take one of the gold ones
and bring it in the shower which is fine
because I'm like okay hers is in the
shower mine's out here and then I gotta
bring mine in the shower I bring mine in
the shower and then I put it down like
wait a minute which one's mine the Gold
ones are mine dude it's so gross to use
someone else's toothbrush and let me
tell you why not because of the brushing
the teeth because some people brush
their tongue
dude that's disgusting but you [__]
you're Mack it all the time on it yeah
hang on if you're macking if you're
[__] got your Mac on and your Mac in
Non-Stop with your mouth on the other
one macking away what the [__] is the
difference between that and sharing a
toothbrush just illness this Stillness
okay it's a fresh ass toothpaste on it
Mackin is about fresh kissing mix of
saliva yeah beautiful temperature yeah
you know my temperature in my mouth is
meeting your temperature of your mouth
okay this is love making okay okay using
a stale toothbrush that someone else
brushed their [__] tongue on or got
the [__]
lettuce out of their teeth come on with
that but it's the realness and that's
why you don't like it because you don't
like the realness which is what it
actually is which is what I'm talking
about but like who cares you're not
you're not seeing it happen like I don't
know that [__] only grosses me out when
like I'm visualizing it or seeing it
everyone who cares walking through the
door that's okay
all right well it's a it's a truth I
like that you did that that's fine
what's this we're opening the garage
somebody drove out with a bunch of
people
dude it's just disgusting you don't
think it's disgusting and here's the
other thing if they actually don't I
really just I don't yeah if I was gonna
pick somebody
to do this with it would be Kristen of
course exactly which is why it's not
gross
it's still gross it's not gross dude
it's not gross she should divorce you
that you think it's gross it means you
don't love her if you loved her you
wouldn't [__] care dude does she care
it's yours no because she actually loves
you
[Music]
I'll adjust you yeah uh no I just I
don't I don't think it's gross and if
you think it's gross I think that's
weird that's just my take on it dude I
don't know what to say it's like you're
macking away you Mack all the time on
each other's mouths like who [__]
cares
also how annoying is it to
me getting all the toothbrushes and then
her still using for my tooth that's
that's a bit like is she trying to I
mean it's a little bit yeah it's like
that's like gangster [__] yeah that is
actually it's pretty baller to be like
yeah I'm gonna use the gold ones how
many gold toothbrushes around my
bathroom right now for real they're all
I mean I'll take a picture of it and
I'll send it in is there a way to put
like a label on it like a tape with a
letter on it frankly I don't think that
that would matter yeah but we do have a
label maker yeah you have a label maker
try it out dude okay I'll try it out and
same advice for uh this woman but it
sounds like he gets the idea now like I
would imagine that if you call your
partner out on it for doing it that they
don't like it that they would stop
obviously Christian's such a [__]
hard ass baller doesn't want to do that
this woman's husband might actually
respect her wishes and stop so maybe you
don't even need advice
all right cool anyway next
Chris what's up man I just got a quick
question
Chris man every time you talk about
Jacksonville intuitives you speed past
it like a homeless guy and you don't got
any tit in your car you heard like you
talk about it like a 40 year old guy
talks about getting his prostate check I
need you to put some love on
Jacksonville's name on the tour dates
man you just be that's all I said you
know so I just need I know like we love
you not hear dogs oh I love it too hard
my girlfriend watches this podcast
though
[Music]
wow definitely had a hair not on his
pubes too I think I think uh I think
well I I speed past it you know why
because it's [__] the last one that I
have and I and I I'd like I feel like
I'll I'll start giving it love as it
moves on I will be in Jacksonville
chrisley.com but the thing is I I know
it's the last one and it's also selling
very well so why don't you tell them how
you feel about Jacksonville so he
doesn't have his feelings I love Jackson
but you've ever been uh Florida no
Jacksonville North Carolina the north of
Florida is pretty [__] up honestly
never been yeah uh Jacksonville to be
honest
if I were gonna like it you know if I
was gonna live there it would be is
Jacksonville the north of Florida
depression yeah oh okay
um they I was I was staying at a
Radisson in once and the show was in the
Radisson in so whoa yeah whoa that's
[__] weird huh yeah
[__] my back up so hard that trip how
come just woke up one day and it was
[__] up and I'm talking about
and I'm talking about I couldn't move
dude that's the worst I couldn't move
and I did this and it finally sucked it
up did the show
got heckled so hard no security I mean
just [__] it probably had to do
because the show was in the Radisson in
but yeah um yeah it was definitely uh
not uh uh you know the only thing I did
every day I was there for the weekend I
walked to Whole Foods and there wasn't
even a sidewalk to it it was like you
had to like go over swamps you know it's
like Florida yeah
Florida like that you gotta like walk
over overpasses and [__] it's so weird
dude also Florida will have like legit
like swamps like like as big as this
room and they're just there in the
middle of the whole area yeah yeah and
it's like literally like [__] Ikea is
down is like within walking distance and
you're like why is there a swamp here
they're like toads and lily pads and
[__]
[__] Frodo's there
it's so weird anyway I do love
Jacksonville but mostly because you can
collect bags in Jacksonville but anyway
next one
what up boys so close so close
finishing up some cardio what's up guys
sorry strongness but so I have a
question so I'm getting married in like
seven months right and the only thing my
fiance keeps telling me is not all about
you I know you love to dance it's not
all about you it's my wedding you know
it's my time to shine which I am I get
it you know but I am Kevin Bacon from
Footloose I like your boy likes to dance
I like it and she's clearly one of the
rest of the carnies in that City and
doesn't like dancing as much as I do so
my question is should I you know be
considered and not dance as much still
the stock spot like because I clearly
what so I just dance because this is the
biggest most expensive party I'm ever
gonna have so might as well Live It Up
all right guys appreciate y'all like
ribs that's right it does my first piece
of advice is start watching Footloose
less than he does but I think watch it
more beyond that dude dance as much as
you want at your own wedding
what the [__] is this woman trying to do
also don't marry her no I think the
hilarious this is hilarious that sh
you're lit like asking someone not to
dance is the most symbolic thing of all
time yeah dude I just need to dance and
she's like no yeah divorce her like he's
like give me all your money and she's
like boom like putting the [__] right
finger in them okay everything's not bro
dance dance is the one thing you're
supposed to be able to do whenever you
want you let loose it symbolizes freedom
say is this Kuwait to her I don't know
if they can dance it or not but it
sounds like they can't but like wow dude
profiling Kuwait so hard yeah I do it
and dude I just it that is so big babe
the one thing I Like To Do Is Dance Let
Me dance please everything else can be
for you but in this wedding when they
play [__] shout or whatever terrible
song
dude when they go a little bit louder
now
baby right around that's such a wedding
song is it yeah dude yeah dude don't say
no no I don't know I don't think proceed
keep going don't don't the worst
childhood
You Spin Me Right Around baby right
around in a Mecca wrecking round and
around now actually they just say the
same words over and over again you
didn't need to do the Western yeah
[Laughter]
yeah western bacon cheese
that you were working with that one time
remember oh that he said is that the
Western mechan beckon oh yeah dude is
that the Western making bacon
cheeseburger just added bacon adding wow
you speaking you know meccan yeah you
don't say that it does kind of it is
kind of nice in there though western
bacon Mac and cheeseburger it sounds
cool yeah yeah you got nice with it um
yeah dance dude you got to tell her dude
if I get go walk up through just your
advice walk up to her and be like look
or work on a dance just spring it on or
show it to her and then be like that's
what I want to do with the wedding is
that okay I need to dance dude I need to
dance I think you also need to ask her
honey why don't you want me to dance she
doesn't want him to take away from her
day
it's his day too I know but it's but you
dude when you get married it's like I
don't know you've got to kind of shut
the [__] up as the groom I don't trust
this woman dude this is gonna go badly
no you do know her I don't I did not
trust this woman for you I like this guy
he seems like a good guy sweethearted
guy loves to dance I just I don't
you're not on board with his marriage
you could say dance with me she probably
you know what it is she doesn't like the
way he dances well yeah he probably
dances terrible he probably dances silly
yeah and it probably sucks to be
perfectly honest he probably sucks at
Dancing Yeah you do you suck at dancing
yep dance better your wife would love it
yep all right next
same guy hey Matt hey Chris Chris out of
Houston Texas with take number four
coming at you wow so dangerously driving
and doing this video Let's drop on beers
perfect another work phone did a ding
right when I was about to be done oh I
hate that cool uh why don't you get your
advises on Christmas gifts for the
extended family
a lot of nieces and nephews their
parents don't necessarily get our kids
Christmas gifts uh not a big deal but
um just wanted to get your thoughts with
the holidays coming up right around the
corner things are expensive uh we live
away from family there most of them are
up in Michigan
in Ohio and so anyway just wanted to get
your thoughts on buying Christmas gifts
for your entire extended family should
you do it or should you save those bags
for later anyway thank you guys love
what you're doing
dude if they don't do it for you
definitely don't yeah yeah but I also
think that Christmas should be about you
know I I don't I don't think it should
necessarily be about gift giving I think
it's nice to do that with your immediate
family your kids your wife your your
sister your brother or something if you
have an older brother maybe getting
something nice you know what I mean
um but this the the people you meet up
with I think it that should be Christmas
should be about family you know I mean
you look at them you go if Vin Diesel
says Fast and Furious about family It
Fast and Furious about family then
definitely Chris about family nobody's
giving each other gifts and Fast and
Furious you didn't see [__] Vin
Diesel give Tyrese a [__] Sundial you
didn't see that because it's about
family so basically Christmas is
treatable Fast and Furious you're
talking so fast right now dude I wasn't
back in making cheeseburger you're just
like eliminating words you're limiting
half everyone got it everyone got it
yeah I got it but I'm just getting
worried oh I'm gonna fart dude I think I
think it should be more about family and
honestly you know for the immediate
family the people that be basically the
people that you've decided to share your
life with every single day and look at
them or anybody that came out of your
nut sack or your vagina that is who you
get the gifts for okay anybody that
splits blood with you maybe I get
something for you you get something for
me nice right yeah but besides that it's
about family it's about eating a turkey
[__] drumstick with each other
uh don't he said in the video that they
don't get your kids anything right well
that's so this very simple answer is do
not get them anything there's nothing
else to it don't be like the better
person and get gifts they don't even
they don't [__] respect you enough to
get presents for your kids the better
person then you don't do it dude you're
going to be poor so you know don't
[__] spend your money as a better
person if they're not being [__]
expensive yeah dude no save that money
to spend on your own kids and their
gifts I agree
fully
yeah [__] them okay [__] them all first
therapist
Christmas is about [__] them all get him
get him a card anyone opens and say [__]
you you didn't get [__] for my kids all
right next
Chris Matt what's going on my name is
Marcus love the podcast Chris I love
your podcast been watching it for a long
time here's my question
do I
let my ex-girlfriend
see the dog we raise together oh man
um
after a breakup even though we had an
agreement because we had two dogs that
one person gets one dog and another
person gets the other dog and she gave
up her dog and she wants to come see the
other dog because she helped raise it
what do I do I have a very hard line
about this me too go ahead what no me
too you can't do it yeah and if it comes
down to it quite frankly you gotta give
the dog to her agree because and I know
how heartbreaking that is I've had to do
that once crazy ass [__] girlfriend I
I it was like oh no well why don't you
keep this one dog and I'll just take and
I was like I know you you're so [__]
crazy yeah you're gonna use that as a
wrench to get back into the [__] mix
take them sayonara I'm sorry dude I love
you but like you got to go with the
crazy woman now yeah mine wasn't crazy
but I I I we broke up she left me so
deeper and um you know
uh and she took and and she she moved
out I got the doll log and we were gonna
kind of like she was like I'll see the
dog sometimes and then
and then like a year went by the dog
literally helped me through the breakup
and then she was like she got a new
relationship and she was like I want to
have the dog wow I was like oh [__] it
was either that or separate the
visitations for you know separate the
visitations and then and then
um I was like okay I was on the road
starting to do the road a lot so I was
like just keep the dog and then she kept
the dog and it it it it it was better
for the dog I guess because I was on the
road and [__] and she probably better
for you too why because you didn't have
to deal with the crazy mess right right
well yeah yeah yeah the message is here
yeah
um and so I give the dog up and I miss
that dog even still but you know as time
moves on it gets a little better I say
give her the dog it's probably better
for the dog to be with the other dog
anyway right or or if you insist on
keeping the dog tell her she can't see
it you guys had a [__] deal you had
an agreement right she's trying to
[__] inch her way back in your life
that's not the way to do it if she wants
that that she used to come out right and
say it she wants to see the dog too
[__] bad I want to [__] I want my
dead dog to come back to life it just is
not how life works right right you made
a deal you got to stick to it you
experienced a death sweetheart you gave
up your dog the dog's dead to you yeah
we had a we had a deal yeah be a
hardballer we'd [__] the deal art of
the deal and then [__] and then
you'll have the confidence right that's
Trump yeah just like this okay
hello you know go like this and
we had a deal
yep that's right we had to deal The
Dog's Mind [__]
if you'd like to make a call a message
C4
that used to happen in the age before
okay not C4 because that's Dynamite next
one
is
the best and you've gotten me through
some really hard times with Chris so
thank you keep it up
I just wanted to get some advice on a
drunken friend that I've had for a
really long time we used to party
together she got a DUI learned
absolutely nothing from it wow beautiful
and I ended up getting a DUI and changed
my life and I'm now seven months sober
beautiful always pushes alcohol on me
even though she knows that I can't be
drinking and I don't want to be a drink
not a good friend and the last time that
she came over to my house
she totally ditched me I made her dinner
and we were supposed to paint so I got
all that stuff ready and then she left
she promised she'd be back and then like
an hour and a half goes by and she
didn't show back up so I'm just
wondering what I should do should I just
stop being her friend should I talk to
her about these things even though it
probably won't get better probably won't
or should I just find some new friends
get rid of the negative
toxicity in my life and just find people
that want to hang out with me for me so
I just want to have a silly goose time
yeah without alcohol it seems to be hard
it's tough so thanks guys see you
November 5th Chris Denver
and yeah of course without comp Denver I
I think uh she's not I know we use this
term loosely and we think of our friends
as people who have they've always been
someone so has been my friend forever
but there Comes A Time sometimes
that person ceases to be your friend
because they are not treating you the
way a friend treats another friend this
is an instance of that this girl is not
being your friend you had a whole
[__] plan you went out to get paint
supplies she promised she's going to
come back she goes out and probably
[__] gets drunk and just ditches your
ass dude she's trying to get you to
drink even though you're sober this is
not this is not what friends do she's
got her own [__] problems she's
trying to [__] Pawn them off on you
or bring you back from [__] Health
into the depths of the addiction and
this is not she's not this is not good a
preacher I am a preacher dude into the
depths of the addiction that she has
ceased to be your friend yeah dude it's
true um she's not your friend yeah I
agree I think it's a bigger issue than
just that I think that this person is
suffering from addiction and it's a lot
harder for her than it is for you she
also doesn't want to stop and she
doesn't want to stop right she has not
hit the she has not hit the proverbial
Rock Bottom yeah dude and uh I feel like
um you've got to be there as a friend
you might want to mention something it
might not help but it might and you know
you might be the Rock Bottom she needs
like look I I want nothing I want
nothing to do with you this you're
you're affecting my life so much and
it's tough man it's really tough to see
your friends and suffer from addiction
and because it affects your
relationships because also you're sober
and you're you suffer from addiction you
know if you do and
um and it's it's tough It's it's just a
you would you know
it that disease is destroying that
lady's life and
um you owe it to her as a friend to
maybe mention it to her and if she's
going to react to the way she reacts
then that's on her and that's that's
just how it's gonna have to be and that
sucks but yeah dude that sucks man I
mean like you want it to paint dude
you're talking about somebody that
wasn't allowed to dance and somebody
that isn't allowed to [__] paint all
on this episode the world's a sad place
what you gotta do is dance and paint and
I'm serious the difference between these
two people though is that I feel if my
heart goes out to this woman my heart
does not go down to the dance guy
why I don't care about that guy I care
about her though he's he's not a good
dancer he needs to get better at that
he's probably not a good dancer but you
think she's a good painter but paintings
this is not she's not in the same
situation you're saying it's
Therapeutics she didn't her friend
didn't not come back because she was
like oh so-and-so is not a good painter
yeah yeah I got you you know what I'm
saying right uh so is like apples and
oranges but uh dude yeah there are other
people out there who are sober who or
even those who are not sober who treat
sober people with the respect that they
[__] require yeah this woman is
disrespecting you she's not your [__]
friend right she just is not I know I
get that but you don't think this is
that's my advice I'm saying
that looks pretty therapeutic I'll be
honest
wow
I can't believe it an old lady that
can't believe it
[Laughter]
oh [__] wow
that's really the best one ever did an
old lady that can't believe wow dude
oh [__]
oh [__] dude oh [__] man wow
dude I love when you do it when you're
like when you when you do it but you you
do it prematurely not you but like
whoever's doing it and they say can't
believe it and then they fix it and say
an old lady that can't believe it it
comes out faster because they're so
excited
[__] man oh [__] it was already hot in
here and now I'm [__] just oh first
draft Nelly
it was already hot in here now two out
wait a minute what about if it's just
high in
oh [__] all right cool got a little
light-headed yeah yeah all right all
right cool you got another one or what
[__] next one last one to drive it on
the last one so drunk Chris goes this is
the last one got electrocuted the most
beautiful hair of all time
hey Matt hey Chris uh I'm Jess a 31 year
old woman from Montreal Canada and I'm
seeking advice for
relationship breakups like how to go
through a breakup when you're still like
deeply in love with the person and what
the difference is between compromises
and sacrifices in a relationship
yeah yeah thanks
I mean uh sacrifice is something you
actually give up a compromise is
something that you meet halfway on or
meet somewhere in the middle on
compromise is like well I like to do it
this way and then she's like well I like
to do it that way and then you figure
out a way that it works somewhere in the
middle of both of those sacrifice is
like you know you quit smoking for
somebody you you stop staying out late
for somebody you stop drinking for
somebody whatever uh sacrifices you cut
something out of your life compromises
you meets you meet in the middle yeah I
mean I feel like the the sacrifice is I
look at it as giving gifts you know like
here's the deal dude if you both want to
go on vacation uh next year well they
broke up right that's what she's saying
she's saying advice on breakups because
I'm really still in love with right but
uh so the correct so is she is she still
with them oh no no they broke up and she
still so I think I'm assuming yeah so
like next year
say we're a romantic couple right we're
a romantic couple no you don't have to
say it but like just think that we are
right and then like like we [__]
sometimes and we go on vacations
yeah yeah I mean I you know whoever
you're with two people but yeah that's
for us for the example but yeah you're a
woman and I'm just like you got big tits
and stuff right now we're talking okay
yeah so um so anyway we we
I want to go to Mexico on vacation next
year you
don't want to go to Sweden I'd rather go
to Sweden okay so you know I'm like okay
well where do you want to go second
because I don't want to go to Sweden you
don't want to go to Mexican right no
matter how big your tits are I want to
go [__] I want to go somewhere else
right because I don't want to Sweden so
you say well what about you know um
Mallorca Spain okay but okay what about
Japan no that's not really like Sweden
or anything okay all right cool so um
it's a big but um
and you try to whittle it down to you go
to a place where you compromise where
you want to go right yeah that's
an awful thing to do oh and I will tell
you why this year we go to Sweden of
course that next year we go to Mexico
now you're typically big ball places but
but what we do is compromise but it it's
it's a bit of a sacrifice though isn't
it
but it's a bit of a sacrifice though
isn't it I mean it is because I don't
get to do what I want this here but I'm
giving you a gift we'll go to Tokyo this
year and you give me a gift next year so
you came up with one example that proves
that I'm not exactly right all the time
is that all you've done but what I'm
saying is if you look at it if you
reframe it in your mind instead of
saying a sacrifice says I'm giving a
gift to my partner and this benefits us
both right because I want my partner to
be happy and I'm going to be happy I'm
just you know going to be giving a gift
instead of actually doing what I want to
do and that's fine and no big deal right
but as you can see your titties bounce
all over the world we stopped with the
titties part because that's not thing
that that's neither here nor there okay
uh not for me but but yeah I mean I
don't actually don't know how this
relates in her mind the compromise
sacrifice and the breakup thing yeah but
uh yeah compromise is
sacrifice is much more like dramatic a
compromise is a thing you need to be
able to do to make a relationship last
long right you know uh sacrifices are
what make relationships exist at all in
any form you know
um but about Break of advice
[__] that guy if you broke up you
probably book up for a reason and it's
probably good
um the thing about young people and I
know it's not like we're [__] old but
like really young people like under 25
31 but she was 31 well she looks 22. I
know uh but 31 is still pretty young but
I think that the older you get the more
experience you have the more
relationships you're in the more likely
you are to recognize the fact that
the feeling of oh my God I'm never going
to meet someone I love that much again
I'm never going to meet someone who puts
up with this and that thing about me
it's just not true because you're going
to and you know this because you have
done it right before over and over and
it's always true it's always true that
you will find someone else yep
it's never not true do you believe in
the one that's got The One That Got Away
absolutely [__] not really yeah dude
wow it is it is a [__] fallacy that
is not true the one Ah that's the one
that got away like that that's not an
accurate assessment of reality you can
think that because our minds are wired
to make narratives out of our own lives
but that's not accurate in any way wow
there's no such thing as The One That
Got Away what about so there's maybe
like the two or three that cut away but
like maybe I'll find another one you
absolutely will find another one as long
as you're not just [__] in the past
hung up on the One That Got Away the
thing your brain is making up on for
whatever [__] reason you know yeah
it's just it's it's not it's only as
true as you allow it to be
um yeah okay
yeah okay yeah you're probably right
about that so you don't believe in soul
mates
nah no I don't even believe in Souls
[Music]
and there you have it everyone yeah I
don't believe in Souls yeah
um I mean soul mates it's like I believe
that people mean it and believe it when
they're in a relationship with someone
they feel so deeply connected to but if
that relationship were to crumble guess
what you ain't [__] soul mates so
there's no version of the soulmate that
gets away because soul mates don't get
away if your relationship starts to
crumble just trust in God oh yeah dude
gotta bring it back to GNN this is the
earthquake show you either have
sacrifice or compromisation
all right well all right well that's it
dude good way to end this we had a good
time uh you want a one-on-one advice
session with macro to matalia.com book
them up I'm getting full baby
uh or go to watch lifeline.com if you
got a question click the link below you
can go to lifelinemerch.com and get that
spin movement mentality hoodie it's
getting it's fall coming up false
creeping up get that [__] crew
neckline oh baby yeah so and then also
uh we have our live show coming up
October 19th get tickets for that in the
comment below Matt it's his birthday
October 19th uh 6 p.m Pacific Time or as
I like to say specific time uh that's
when we will be doing Lifeline Live join
us live we'll be taking your calls and
talking with you and everyone who gets
on the show gets this piece of signed
merch thank you very much you guys you
guys
this is the first podcast about you
lifeline
[Music]